hi I'm Josh Rubenstein a designer on
smash and grab today I'm going to play a
match in Steel City using ten blade to
show you how some of the team tactics
work in our game Here I am inside the
subway station this is where each team
begins the match you see me hitting here
a vending machine I'm going to get a
sprint boost so that I can get to the
middle to match faster right in the
middle of the map there's a box one box
will spawn every two minutes but at the
beginning of the match one box spots
right off we're going to get that box
we're going to try to bring it back to
our base now this is a big objective
it's worth a lot of money and the first
team to get to $50,000 wins so the other
team is going to be going for this for
sure I'm getting here a damage boost so
that when they come i'm going to be
ready for them now they've sent two
people to the middle while the other one
is appearing to go and gather weapons so
I'm outmatched here luckily my teammate
is coming along and we've got a nice to
v2 in the center I just use my special
ability there and he looks like he's
about down for the count
don't take out his lieutenant first this
is important because his lieutenant can
kill him we're going to try to get away
with the box and we've made a little bit
of a headway here but they're really
pushing and they're really trying to not
let us go he's now killed himself with
his player ability which deals high
damage but also deals damage to himself
he neglected to notice that he would be
killing himself if you did that so off I
go with the box it's me and my team mate
rip off now drip off is really great at
control in space so in this sort of
situation I would expect drip off to go
and make some space for me you can see
the buffs that I have active because of
the two kills that I've got I've got a
couple stacks of deadly grace which
means I'm going to be a much more
effective box carrier because a movie
faster so there's drip often as I
expected he is trying to stop enemies
from approaching me there's a fast
travel exit there so it's a likely
attack vector for enemies but he's
keeping the fort down and my other
teammate run in to join the fray and
I've returned the box successfully so
we've taken a nice early lead I was
thinking about using the fast travel
there but I decided not to because I'd
like to get the kill here and build up
my deadly grace tax a little bit more so
now that we've seen a little bit of
action i'm going to tell you about the
team that I've chosen so in smash and
grab each player controls a team of five
characters a leader which I'm
controlling directly am I lieutenant who
you can see over there with a symbol
over her head that's sharp and she's
doing her herd stun ability using her
stun gun which will allow me to follow
up and the final gang members are
soldiers and there are three sort of
faceless moops who fill out the roster
and they're not particularly deadly
alone but in numbers they can be quite
overwhelming
each player on my team and there are
three players on my team gets to have a
roster of five characters like this so
you saw drip off earlier and as his
lieutenant he is using catch who is a
looter specialist catch can find extra
looting stores so if you watched ripoffs
icon on the mini-map you'll see that
he's going around to the stores as early
as possible in order to make full use of
caches ability to get the maximum amount
of extra money there I've just taken a
an embarrassing loss but it was a to be
won and tying up them for long enough
that my teammates could go and get some
of the map was probably worth it I've
responded my subway station and the
Sprint bonus that I broke the vending
machine for is just sitting there
waiting for me yeah which is perfect
it's a good reason why I broke the
vending machine early on because they
keep dispensing him about every two
minutes so breaking the vending machines
early lets your team collect more
power-ups as the match goes on now see
I've moved away from the store the drip
off was looting this is important
because drip off gets stronger as he
loots more so if I were to take that
loot I would be denying him power and
effectively denying my team error so the
enemy is now getting away with a box and
my teammate there etch who's a ranged
character is doing his best to stop the
somme the box from getting away but he
isn't much of a frontline fighter so
you'll see that as I'm tying up the
enemies he's trying to find a spot where
he can sort of be sneaky and and shoot
into the melee
unfortunately he just got taken out as
he wasn't able to get away from the
opposing leader but it was a good effort
nonetheless so rip off and I have now
decided that we're going to let this one
box go because it is just too far into
enemy territory and now we're coming up
with a new plot because the opposing
team has to light characters on it the
best maneuver would be for us to go and
deny the light weapons to them I'm still
on the rent one light weapon which is
not great and I'd love to upgrade and in
about 20 seconds you can see the round
timer at the top the next tier of
weapons stores is going to open now when
they do I saw that the opposing leader
nil he didn't have his weapon upgrade
yet so he's definitely going to want to
go for it too so this is going to be a
nice way to bait him into giving us a
free kill because the three of us are
waiting here and there are only three
machetes that's the tier 2 light weapon
their only three machetes in the store
so with all three of us here we can
fully deny it so you see my teammates
have now each taken one machete and yep
there's nail he took the bait has to be
predicted he's dead and I'm going to go
grab the last machete for a nice upgrade
for myself and you can see that the
store is now dark so there are no more
machetes available that means that
because their team has light characters
they are going to be one weapon upgrade
down for the remainder of this realm
that is a really big deal because it
means we have class them in terms of
damage and then we can win the team
fights very easily which means we're
dominant in the boxes so here I am doing
a one-on-one against scatter and
opposing leader this guide is pretty
tricky but once you get up close to him
it's very difficult for him to disengage
unless he gets a nice counter off on you
you can see I've got a little target
over my head scatters playing lieutenant
called graves who marks targets and
makes them worth more money of course
that's only if they're killed which I
wasn't
so here I've just dodged that that's a
very hard ability to dodge don't quite
proud of myself there and it looks like
I'm going to be outmatched in this area
so I'm just going to have to go back to
my face oh you see me they're just using
the crew command that's because the rest
of my gang is going to die to nil there
and I told them to follow me so that
they don't waste their time fighting him
since they really have no chance to
being so numbered like that I wanted to
save their lives two of them did make it
back to me the other two unfortunately
did the hide to nil so he's now fighting
me right in front of my subway station
this is a little bit foolish because the
subway station is a source of healing so
if I feel like I'm in trouble I can
usually just go back in there and fill
up so Neil died and now his lieutenant
is going to be taken out goodbye
monolith and then we're going to go
rejoin our team so they've already
started to make headway on the third box
and I'm going to use the fast travel now
to go over there and join them ok so
here I am on the other side of the map
nil is trying to stop them from getting
a strong box now I've used my crippling
blade ability which is going to slow him
down and I know that he's alone because
I just killed him so I basically went to
his spawn just as he was coming out no
but he's got me with that flare ability
so I'm quite at a disadvantage here so I
think I'm gonna have to run but as I'm
doing so my teammates were making good
headway with the box this is important
because there are only three players on
one team tying up a single player or two
players while you type them around can
really give the rest of your team the
freedom to dominate them out so I've
I've died but I feel like it was worth
it however nil is quite mobile as he can
keep running even when he's out of
stamina at the cost of his own health so
he's making his way back to the Box
really quickly
I've now got to go and try to intercept
them and make the team fight around the
box be a three-on-three you can see
their drip off and catch are already
holding down the fort and I'm going to
charge right through and try to take out
a leader now remember is we're still one
weapon upgrade up on these guys so we
should win this teamfight pretty handily
because we are outclassing them pretty
heavily in terms of damage
well it looks like he's uh doesn't have
much chance left to win here oh shoot
unless yeah well this one might be down
to the wire out there he goes okay looks
like we're going to get the box after
all now the heavy weapons store hasn't
yet been looted by drip off and I don't
have a weapon market so that might be a
nice little objective for me to do so
you can see drip off has got a weapon
mod there that's a poison axe we call it
the contaminants these are the weapon
Watts has a fun little name like that
now I'm going to try to make some space
for him to continue taking the box there
we go I've held down kneel for a little
bit ten blade is a disabler so part of
her role is to disable opponents and
prevent them from getting to your
teammates unfortunately the box did end
up flipping hands there I'm going to
grab a sprint bonus and try to get back
into the mix okay so what I'd really
like to do here is take out this last
leader and cut us a clear path to get
back at the pass now this is a up scribe
that we're fighting over here he is kind
of an all-rounder leader he can heal
himself he can do a rally command that
makes him speed up now a rally command
is an order that you can give to your
game which will make them to a certain
behavior in up scraps case they support
him in whatever he's doing and they get
a speed boost so he can also give
himself the speed was with
so they have decided that what they're
going to do is use the fast travel and
try to prevent us from taking the box
back they're just going for a straight
throw their heads against it strategy
but because the defensive nature of the
box it's got that shock ability which
you just saw and the fact that we're so
close to our base I think we'd have the
definite advantage here so we should be
able to pull it out without too much
trouble but it does look like they
actually managed to take out one of my
teammates in there subscribe getting
away with that rally command I told you
about it actually looks like we're going
to lose the box this time okay so
earlier I mentioned you know about when
it's time to let the Box go I think what
we're going to do is just get this one
kill here and go start upgrading our
weapons and hitting the other stores on
the map because that box is probably a
lost cause this point they did a really
good job of getting it out of our spawn
that's difficult to do okay so we're
going to let that box go and we're going
to try something a little bit riskier so
it's not immediately apparent but in
about ten seconds another box is going
to be dropping so there's going to be
two boxes available on the field not
counting the one that's being taken back
right now so I'm going to get the one in
the north and my teammates are going to
go for the one that's just about to drop
and you're going to see it up here on
the map in just a second and what we're
going to try to do is take two boxes
back at once so there's not really any
way for the opposing team to stop them
both
so just so that they don't really get
what's going on I'm going to start by
looting because otherwise they're going
to get at a notification on the mouth I
also need some help so I definitely do
fill up so i told my soldiers there to
loot by giving them an order and while
they're doing that I'm going to break
the Box open pick up the shock box and
grab a sprint boost now while I'm doing
that you can see that my teammates are
going to start making a play for the
other box so they're starting to loot
they're going to get some more cash and
they're going to own the center of the
map on give me space to work so I'm not
actually going to try to take this all
the way back because I believe that the
fast travel on our side is going to be
really dangerous for me if the
opponent's see me getting too close to
it they're going to jump in the fast
travel on their side and they're going
to come right out you can see I've got
more stacks of deadly grace now so I'm
actually pretty quick drop the Box down
and then we're going to get started on
the next one you can see my teammates
there are fighting for it and we're
going to make sure that we have it the
enemy teams got it we're so going to
need to em to take them off of it but
once we do you can see that our deadly
plan is going to come to fruition here
that was obscure I've that I just took
out there now they didn't end up going
for the rank free weapons after all even
though they're on their side I think
they sort of got the notion that if they
didn't stop me from taking the box back
on the left then that would be the end
of their chances to win so you can see
my teammates are fighting over the box
in the center and there's really not a
whole lot the opposing team can do about
it now because the boxes have now
entered a position where if they go for
either of them then the other ones just
going to get back without too much
trouble so a box is worth 10,000 but
that's not going to want us to match out
right so one of my teammates is going to
have to get the last little bit just by
looting a store that shouldn't be too
difficult to do because here comes
scatter and he's fighting me in my spawn
which is pretty foolish given that the
spawn heals you so I'm just going to get
basically infinitely healed while he's
in here good my lieutenant sharp did
this down on him allowing me to get an
easy to her wounds and take the box back
you can see in the time that laughs my
team make up the last little bit of loot
and we've got the win so there you have
it you did a match in Steel City we saw
some team tactics between ourselves in
our gang and some team tactics between
ourselves and other allied leaders and
we saw how the best strategy isn't
always the most obvious one thanks for
watching hope to see you in the game